hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast and unbiased view of the next
generation sequencing market we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's I'm
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or submit
your problem through green join a button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Shaun Baker co-founder
and chief science officer of all seek I
will now turn it over to Sean for his
presentation thank you for the
introduction Judy and thank you all for
attending this presentation so as we
stated this will be an unbiased view of
the next generation sequencing market
and what I want to do is take you
through a few of the trends that we've
seen at all seek but before I do that I
need to explain to you who all seek is
and why we think we have this unbiased
view all seek has created the sequencing
marketplace so this is sort of like
match.com
but rather than being for people looking
for dates it's for researchers who are
looking for sequencing services so what
we've done is we build a series of free
online tools that helps researchers
describe the experiments that they want
to do their sequencing experiments and
then we match them up with the providers
who can offer those services but a key
point of this is that we don't actually
offer the services ourselves and we
don't own any sequencing instruments so
we feel this gives us an unbiased
neutral standpoint and when you combine
that with a large number of experiments
that we see coming through the
sequencing marketplace we feel it gives
us a really unique perspective on the
market really interesting insights and
some of those insights that I'm going to
share with you today okay so let's start
in with the first trend this is the big
one that you know everyone's been
talking about for a little while and
that's the thousand dollar genome and
the big thing here is that it's finally
here this is something that's been
talked about for a long time so we're
all really excited to be finally have it
sort of there's a caveat here that I'm
gonna walk you through so the first
thing is what was able to generate this
thousand dollar genome and that's the
high seek x10 instrument from aluminum
so this is their latest and greatest
machine it is people were generating 600
Giga bases of output per day that
translates to over a 1.8 trillion bases
per run and that's enough data for them
for that instrument to generate around
five whole human genomes per day and
that translates to over 1,800 genomes
per year when you run a day in and day
out which is what they expect so how
does this work what's what's it got
that's different from the machines that
were that used to be out there primarily
it's these patterns flow cells this is a
lot of the lumina to pack in a lot more
data for run and a lot easier prep for
it as well and of course when you have
more data a higher density you need to
improve optics to be able to capture all
that data so that's that's basically
what they've done so this sounds really
great
latest and greatest from Illumina the
market leaders lots and lots of data
what's what's the catch here the catch
is that while there are lots and lots of
things that people like to do with their
sequencers lots of organisms they like
to sequence and lots of applications
they like to run the high seek x10 is
highly limited in fact it can only work
with one organism and that's humans and
not only that it can only do human whole
genome sequencing so that means that you
can't do other really interesting things
like XO more cartilage sequencing you
can't do RNA seek can't do all sorts of
things
just human full genome sequencing but if
you can live without limitation it's
actually a really nice low-cost output
system so so the the main goal here is
to get that thousand dollar gene what
how exactly does that happen how does
that break out the thousand dollars
breaks up like this about eight hundred
dollars of that goes to actual
sequencing reagents the juste 135
dollars goes towards paying off the
instrument of the amortization that
leaves about sixty five dollars for
everything else which is primarily
library prep that includes not only the
kits and the reagents drawing the
library prep but also the labor so
obviously you've got to be a pretty
efficient factory to get your cost down
that low it also the Stiles dollars
doesn't include everything there's
things like overhead you know the
building that the instrument is housed
in the electricity to run it turning on
the lights
it doesn't include data storage or any
kind of involved data analysis but it
does do a pretty good job of delineating
what is available so people can
calculate their actual costs alright so
what would this mean if you wanted to
get your own thousand dollar genome what
would you have to do first thing you got
to do is you've got to buy the
instruments and these are pretty pricey
instruments they cost a million dollars
and they're the most expensive next-gen
sequences
on the market today but the thing is you
actually can't really just buy one it's
called the high seek x10 and that's
because you've got to buy them in it
multiples of at least ten so ten million
dollars is your minimum input just to
get started once you've done that you're
off to the races that you're sitting
there generating some data so how much
is it gonna cost you to actually do this
I talked about how there's enough data
generated that makes instruments for
five human full genomes per day that
tells Nellas each that means every day
you have this instrument turned on it
cost you five thousand dollars and of
course you need to be running this day
and day out so over a year operating
that instrument is going to cost you 1.8
million dollars and again this is the
high seek x10 so you had to buy 10 of
them
so it's actually gonna cost you 18
million dollars a year to run operate
these instruments and to get that
instrument amortization down to only
$135 per genome Illumina had to stretch
it out to a four year lifetime so that
means over four years you're actually
gonna have to spend 72 million dollars
to get that thousand dollar Jeana now
it's all is not lost all seek is here to
the rescue
Illumina is actually sold about twenty
of these instruments and groups of
instruments to researchers and groups
all over the world and we have several
of them that are offering services on
the I'm all seek so you're more than
welcome to use us to try to get access
to these instruments okay the number two
trend that has made a lot of progress
over the past year is that of long reads
so Illumina is the dominant player here
but they're really known for their short
leads long reads are starting to come
into fruition so so why do that short
reads have actually been really really
successful lots of great research lots
of great papers are come on about it but
why might you want to actually use
longer reads one of the primary reasons
for doing at is to look at haplotype in
or phase in so here I'm showing you just
one stylized example of a gene with
three snips we've got an a to T change
and then to C the G changes and so if
you were to sequence this with a short
read sequencer that's what you would see
- the normal sequence and then you'd see
a mix of the altered sequence of these
steps but the thing is for diploid
organisms like humans this is actually a
mixture of two different alleles one
from the mother and one from the father
and if the reads are short enough that
they don't span multiple snips it's
actually really difficult to tell what
the actual allele structure is and in
this one particular example we've got a
couple options so it could be that these
three snips are actually distributed
across the two alleles so that you've
actually got defects in both copies or
it could be that all three defects are
in one allele leaving the other allele
completely intact
and this of course can have some really
significant consequences in medical
genetics whether or not you have a and
intact copy of the allele or not it can
be the difference between having a
disease and being completely
phenotypically normal so obviously a
really important application another
reason that long reads are desired is
getting a good understanding what the
actual repeat structure is so here I'm
showing an example of a CGG
trinucleotide repeat and this is a
repeat that is present in humans and
other organisms and it can be related to
developmental delays so you can have
anywhere from just maybe a couple dozen
easy repeats all the way up to a few
hundred repeats and if you have just
short reads that don't span outside the
smallest region its repeat you actually
can't really map this with any precision
you don't know what the underlying
structure is you won't be able to tell
the difference between what will be the
normal condition or the condition that
will confer disease however if you have
long reads that span through the entire
the entirety of that repeat structure
you can uniquely map them and so you can
get a lot more information here that
just simply isn't available with the
short route with the short beats another
example kind of similar saying we're
looking at some structural variations
here so on the top we have just a simple
repeat on the bottom we have an
inversion structure and again if you
have short reads that don't span outside
this repeated region it'll map to
equally well to all possibilities so you
won't be able to tell it's going on
again we have those long reads they'll
be long enough they'll span outside the
repeat region into the constant region
and they'll be able to be completely
unambiguous lemak so again revealing a
lot more information that you just
really couldn't get from the short reads
sometimes there's some tricks you can do
but in general there's some very serious
hard limitation than what you can do the
short reads
so obviously long beads then have a
place and the leader in generating those
long reeds is Pacific Biosciences
they've been out for a couple of years
and making some really strong
improvements in this area
their average read length is now up to
about fifteen kilobases and that
compares to roughly you know two or
three hundred based lengths from the
other technologies so we're talking
almost two orders of magnitude increase
in in readlyn and they're improving all
the time now there's a few negatives
with this technology one the instruments
quite expensive it's a seven hundred
thousand dollar instrument it's also
very heavy requires specialized flooring
to install it the other thing is kind of
an interesting plus and minus it has a
really high error rate so error rate is
hovering around 13% and that compares to
around 1% down even 0.1% for the other
leading systems so substantially higher
error where it's actually a slight
positive isn't that the error model is
stochastic or random so what this means
is if you take the same region of the
genome in sequence at multiple times
you're very unlikely to see the same
error more than once so what that means
is if you sequence deeply enough you can
actually get really high quality really
low error rate consensus sequence and
actually even better than the low lower
error rate models from Illumina because
those actually have some systematic
error that no matter how deeply your
sequence you're always going to have the
same problem over and over again so for
really high quality sequence PacBio
actually is a good choice it's just more
expensive for output and for the
instrument so another technology that's
used for generating long reads that
people are getting quite excited about
is Oxford nanopore is Minaya and as the
name would imply this is an anaphor
based sequencer and there's a lot of
really interesting exciting things about
this and the primary one is the fact
that it appears to be an an important
secret sequencer that actually works
nanopores our technology that people
have been looking to in trying to
develop for at least 20 years and
continually talking about the promise of
it
until recently you couldn't actually do
it yourself but now the minion has been
created actually really small sequencer
that's that little box right there in
front of a laptop computer little
handheld USB driven sequencer it can
currently generate around a Giga base
per day but the more important thing is
that the reed lengths are very long so
just like PacBio it's got reed links
they can easily go past 10 KB they've
even been some hints that it can go as
high as a hundred Cate years so kind of
really depends on how intact your DNA
now it does have some issues the just
like PacBio the error rate is quite high
so the people who've been using it every
porting error rates anywhere from ten to
thirty percent so that's extremely high
the good news though is that it is
improving so it's being rapidly that's
going to wrap it iterations of the
chemistry and that's really helping that
error rate so in-house Oxford says
they've got that error rate down to
around five percent if not under ten
percent the other thing about this
that's kind of unusual is that it isn't
really a commercially launched system so
it's a little bit difficult to know
exactly what's going on the good news is
it is available in an early access
program and the other good news is that
early access program is really quite
widely distributed so there's several
hundred different research groups all
over the world who are using this
instrument but it is still does make it
a little bit difficult to know all the
details because it's early access they
don't have an actual pricing model they
haven't really talked about exactly what
that's going to cost the other thing is
it's a little bit early on so with that
high error rate we don't know exactly
what the error model is it's looking
pretty good like it can be used to
create very high quality sequence but
it's still not clear it really has that
true stochastic model that PacBio has so
it's something we're going to keep an
eye on in fact they just had a meeting
today
Kalinda and Colin where they talk about
a number of improvements um you know it
just happened so it's I'm still trying
to digest well I can't share it all with
you but it looks like they've done a
number of nice things to it that are
gonna come out over the next several
months to a year
things like faster throughput so it'll
really increase the throughput and over
the cost changing some of the physical
components to it to lower the cost as
well and also increase the number of
fours so all this should translate to a
machine that is easier to acquire and it
produces a lot more data we're just
gonna have to see exactly where that
pans out they also talked about the next
instrument this is the Fermi taeyeon
this is basically a series of those
minions put all together so it's a
higher throughput machine they talk
about some of the specs here today again
it's a bit early but once they have all
the components rolled out they claim to
be able to produce lots and lots of data
with this tera basis of data just like
that high seek x10 but presumably in the
faster time frame and for less money now
this one isn't yet available in early
access unless they announced that today
or maybe tomorrow I'm expecting to see
some news there or fright now it's
something that we're just going to kind
of keep an eye on and it's definitely an
interesting thing to look forward to to
see what Oxford nanopore does so these
two examples that I showed you were
actual true long reads but there's
another strategy you can take and that's
to create synthetic lawn weeds by
piecing together a bunch of small reeds
and one of the first companies to do
this was molecular this is a company
that was acquired by Illumina a couple
of years ago and they Illumina then
incorporated it into their product
lineup they changed the name to true
seek synthetic long reads a bit of a
mouthful so a lot of people just still
call it molecular so what molecular does
is they generate roughly 10 kilobase
synthetic leads so the way they do this
is they take an entire genome and then
they chop it up into roughly 10 killed
fragments and they distribute that
across a 3/4 world plate inside each
individual well those that that DNA is
further fragmented and a unique barcode
is added then the DNA and all the wells
can be pooled back together it can be
additionally fragmented amplified and in
sequence just using the normal aluminum
machines the way that it becomes
interesting is that because those unique
barcodes were added the DNA from each
well can actually be viral dramatically
separated from all the other Wells it's
what that means is when you go to
assemble this and align it to the genome
instead of trying to do that the entire
genome at once you can actually treat
each well as a little mini assembly
project and the result of each little
mini assembly project is a small number
of those 10 KB synthetic reads giving
you essentially 10 KB arethe it's not
quite as good as a true 10 KB read it's
got some limitations or some repeat
structures that it can't really work
through but it does give you a nice way
of giving more information and you can
get with just the short reads themselves
there's another company called 10x
genomics that just came out of stealth
mode a couple months ago they're doing
something similar creating these
synthetic reads but they use a different
process so rather than using a 3d for
well plate they're actually looking at
beads and an oil immersion emulsion so
obviously we're talking much smaller
volumes 10x also uses a much larger
number of barcodes so they can deal with
many more beads molecular was talking
about 3 384 Wells we're now talking
about maybe you know hundreds of
thousands of individual they address
beads a lot lots more barcodes lots more
runway also because of the way they
amplify the DNA they can get longer
reads so the molecular method uses some
form of long-range PCR which kind of
tops out around 10k be 10x genomics is
doing something else allows them to
amplify much larger fragments so they
think they can get synthetically
that are about a 100 Kb and then the
final difference is that 10x is an
automated system so this has some pluses
and minuses the minus is it's a machine
you have to buy so that's about a
$70,000 instrument pretty small though
desktop machine the other the good thing
about it is that it's automated so it's
actually much much easier to use so
people are expecting this to be an
easier system for people to adopt in the
lab okay so that was trend number two of
long reads the third trend I want to
talk to you about is clinical sequencing
and this one obviously has a lot of
importance for how sequencing is
actually being used up to now over the
past at least the past year so next-gen
sequencing really geared just towards
researchers the other ones that all the
companies were trying to sell to and so
therefore they gear their machines and
their kits and their whole way of
thinking so what researchers want where
they want researchers want increased
output they want lower cost of that
output and they want rapid updates as
soon as anything new is available they
want to see it they want to have it in
their lab in their hands clinicians on
the other hand have a completely
different perspective they want to see
is they want a machine that's extremely
easy to use they want a really quick
turnaround time they're dealing with a
patient sample so they need to have a
result as quickly as possible and
perhaps most importantly they want that
machine in that system and that set of
reagents and even the analysis of it to
be as stable as possible so while
researchers would love to have ease
abuse and they would certainly love to
have quick turnaround time this
stability is directly opposed to the
idea of rapid updates so this is a major
change that the sequencing providers the
platform providers have had to come to
terms with basically those clinicians
have to give up those rapid updates in
order to get the stability and if the
researcher wants to use a clinically
valid system they have to give up the
idea of getting those rapid updates so
question that we get a lot is you know
this is all great but when will
in sequencing actually be adopted in the
clinic the answer is it already is so
one of the first applications to really
take off was non-invasive prenatal
testing or an IPP the way of testing
fetal DNA from a simple blood draw from
from the mother and this one is really
taken off and shown to be a pretty big
market in a growing market another one
of course is cancer diagnostics and the
more recently a subset of that is liquid
biopsies so again kind of like ni PT
rather than by op saying the actual
solid tumor looking for clues about the
tumor in in the blood
so basically tumors as they metastasize
and as the cells die they shut off some
DNA into the blood and at high
resolution
that can be detected with these next-gen
sequencing systems another one is the
use of NGS in rare childhood disease
diseases so this is probably not a big
market but it's an important one
children who have developmental problems
we've gone through all the other
diagnostic processes and not have any
answers as to what's going on those
patients are often referred to next-gen
sequencing to try to figure out is there
something else in the genome they can
use to try to at the best give them a
treatment if least just understand
what's going on and maybe avoid some
painful treatments or some expensive
treatments doing the last thing that
we're starting to see is the conversion
of single gene genetic tests into these
multi tuned genetic tests this would
have a couple advantages primarily
probably in terms of ease of use so
rather than doing serial tests one after
the other to try to figure out what's
going on running in either all at once
or many of them at once that can speed
things up and also reduce cost so we're
already seeing this in the market today
and we expect to see this just expand
over time so there are a couple
platforms that are on the market that
are specifically cleared for clinical
use the first was launched by Illumina
and that's the mice TPX this was
launched kind of end of 2013 it was
suppose
to have a follow on with the high seat
which was gonna be released for the ni
PT test but it turns out once alumina
Cade made their sort of mid-range
machine the next week they decided that
was a better fit that's probably the
next fda-cleared instrument we're gonna
see from moving on
Illumina been working with a number of
pharmaceutical companies to generate a
universal NGS oncology test and oncology
containing Diagnostics so that's a way
to get the technology basically adopted
in the clinic as quickly as possible
getting those pharma companies on board
aluminous competitor Ion Torrent which
is owned by thermo followed on about a
year later with their clinically clear
instrument that's the TG MDX and again
just like Illumina they came to the same
conclusion that getting from suitable
companies involved creating these
universal NGS and ecology tests are
really a good way of helping getting
these technologies adopted so there's a
couple of solutions already available
and more are likely to be on the way a
big thing where clinical adoption is
also going to be interpretation so
parking back to this example I should
have before looking at this one stylized
gene you know the clinicians don't want
to see this they don't want to see the
individual sequence they don't even want
to really see the individual snips they
want that turned into something they can
use a true interpretation report they
want something that will tell them maybe
not exactly what to do with their
patient but give them the tools they
need to figure out what they should do
what drugs should they take what
treatment should they have what's the
likely prognosis and so really getting
to that interpretation report as opposed
to raw data is going to be critical so
naturally there's a lot of companies who
are interested in helping them do this
is I've just shown you a few examples
here on the screen there's a very
dynamic field you know we see a lot of
these companies pop into existence and
pop out of existence every year and it's
one of the areas where we really kind of
expect to see some consolidation which
brings us to the fourth trend that we
see in this market today
that's consolidation so the first
company to really do this in a big way
is kaijin
they already had a strong strong hold on
the sample prep market but they wanted
to have tools that would take the user
through the entire workflow samples have
sequencing the data to then analyzing
the data so the first thing they did is
they went on bought a sequencing company
they bought intelligent bio systems your
IBS this is a company that's using a
similar kind of technology to Illumina
sequencing by synthesis it suppose they
have some advantages lower cost lower
error rate and the instrument they're
working on is supposedly going to be
pretty different rather than building a
big one that can handle a lot of samples
at a time they're looking to create a
relatively small one with a modular
structure that can handle one patient
sample at a time unfortunately we
haven't seen too much about this they
bought this company I think over two
years ago and they still haven't
launched it we don't have a hard launch
date hopefully that's progressing we
don't really know but they hygiene has
purchased some other companies as well
to fill his workflow they bought CLC bio
which helps them with the raw analysis
of the data they bought ingenuity which
helps with interpretation and then they
bought bio base which has some
biological databases with that that
interpretation engine can use so if they
get that sequencer to work they will
have a pretty nicely filled out workflow
here but we're still waiting to see all
the pieces that finally come together
another company that's made a lot of
moves in this areas wrote so a couple
years ago wrote who is actually the
first next-gen secrets are on the market
they came out with a four five four they
realized that their machines were
getting outpaced by aluminum so they
tried to buy a little more fortunately
or unfortunately depending on your
perspective Illumina didn't want to be
purchased so they spurned that
advancement and after a while wrote
figured it had to give up so they
stopped trying to acquire Illumina they
also did some other things they
announced the end of life of the 4x4 so
it's actually going to no longer be
supported after mid 2016 that's
basically a dead man walking kind of
platform they also killed off a number
of the partners
they had working with research groups
and other companies to try to come up
with sort of the next generation of
sequencing that would be even better
they killed off a bunch of them so it
really seemed to a lot of people myself
included that it just looked like they'd
given up and they were gonna just get
out of the next-gen sequencing space but
it turns out that's not what they did
they just decided to restart and
retrench and they've made some fairly
bold moves and in terms of acquisitions
and putting some money into some other
companies so again they wanted to fill
out this workload covering sequencing
analysis of the data and then actual
applications of using all that together
so they acquired genius genia is another
nana port company somewhat similar to
Oxford nanopore it uses a slightly
different technology we don't actually
know too much about it these days
because they went kind of dark
after Roche acquired them Roche also
made an investment in Pacific
Biosciences so they cast them to take
their artists to they're big giant long
reads sequencer and make a desktop
version of it that will be useful for
the clinic and that apparently is
progressing we don't really know the
specifics of it it's a private
collaborations and then they're not
really telling the progress but we do
know that Roche has been making payments
for milestone payments for that so
clearly if I was making progress
they also invested in the company called
straddles Stratis genomics isn't a
sequencer per se but what they do is
they're creating some technology that
can help the detection of DNA especially
in Fernan for systems so while they
haven't said it explicitly it certainly
looks suspicious like maybe Jeanie will
start using Stratos technology in the
future assuming things go well Roche
also purchased Benna which creates data
analysis online solutions and hardware
that can accelerate the whole process so
they're trying to get that down and then
they also bought a couple companies
Aereo so which is an ni PT company and
cap Medical which is not too much is
known about them but they're looking at
cancer liquid biopsies this is taking
that next-gen sequencing technology and
actually applying it it also made a
major investment in foundation medicine
they are probably the number one cancer
diagnostic company using next-gen
sequencing and Roche now has a majority
stakeholder so they're making some
pretty bold moves as well really trying
to bring next-gen sequencing to the
market and also kind of leapfrog the
technology that's out there trying to
come up with something better so we'll
see where that goes okay so those are
the four major trends that we see
another thing that I wanted to share
with you today is some of that unique
information that we have access to that
other people don't you took a look in
aggregate at all the projects or going
through our sequencing marketplace and
pulled out some data that we think is
kind of interesting and that's why I
want to share with you so probably
easiest thing to look at its platform
preference I think if you if you did a
poll everyone will get this question
right what's the number one platform
it's aluminum there's really no question
about that
so we're people using sequencing works
who had a preference around 83% of them
wanted an Illumina system so while we
would have guessed it would have been
number one I'm not sure I would have
guessed that we've been so high the
other interesting thing is that for a
second place we actually have a tie
between Ion Torrent and PacBio
so in the past iron torrent has really
been kind of the number two the main
competitor to alumina and PacBio is more
of a niche player but on foreign
unfortunately has been pretty delayed in
their latest product releases and pack
bios making some steady progress
so if that continues you would actually
expect PacBio to take over as the number
two position and then you have the older
systems r45 for install that kind of
round off the grass but those are really
dying off pretty rapidly in terms of
applications again maybe not a huge
surprise here
DNA applications account for about half
of all the products that come through
our sequencing marketplace and this is
roughly slid in equal portions of whole
genome sequencing exome sequencing and
then other forms of smaller targets you
the number two application then would be
RNA or transcriptomics and the vast
majority of this is what I would call
true RNA seek looking at full
transcriptome there's a little bit of
smaller name projects and just a little
bit of that older tag-based DGE type
method but the vast majority is though
is the RNA seek and then there are a
bunch of much much smaller more niche
type applications tip seek metagenomics
methylation things like that so they're
still there people are using them but
they're much longer portion compared to
the fork which is DNA and iron in terms
of species this is another one that was
maybe a little bit surprising to me you
know if you need the trade journals and
you look at the popular press pretty
much all you hear about is these humans
you know how's this going to use for
health what what is this gonna mean for
you directly and it is true it is that
it is the number one species that we see
coming through the sequencing
marketplace but it's actually less than
a third that means there's a whole lot
more variety out there basically you
know bacteria plants mouse fish other
mammals just all sorts of things
anything that can be sequence basically
is being sequence a couple of the
interesting species we've seen come
through there's the guille which is some
sort of African bovine species and then
another one this kind of creeps my wife
out is the deep-sea sea spider so
basically just a tremendous variety of
stuff coming through
humans are important but over two-thirds
are other organisms so this last one is
is a really important question we get it
asked all the time what a sequence are
gonna cost and so you can look at those
prices you can try to see what people
are saying but when it comes down to it
actually having contracts saying you
want X you'll pay Y we actually have
that data so we know exactly what these
sequencing projects are constant so
probably the one that people care about
the most human whole genome sequencing
kind of standards 30x project the
so-called thousand-dollar genome X Prize
cost more than $1,000 of course there
was the cost I didn't I said weren't
included in a thousand dollars things
like the overhead the data storage day
analysis but also in this case profit
these are service providers who are
offering it so they need to pay their
clientele or rather their personnel and
they need to make a profit so the
average price for this is around 1775
little under eighteen hundred and
there's some variability here that's a
standard deviation of a little over two
hundred dollars so what causes that
variability really the number one thing
is number of samples for projects so if
you've come to a provider with just a
handful one two maybe five samples
you're gonna pay a higher price but if
you come to them with much more you know
it's just a hundred even a thousand
you'll start seeing some serious
discounts and you can get prices quite
low you need even see prices as low as
that sort of magical thousand dollars
it's not common we have seen in practice
that well other things that can impact
the cost is the starting material so
obviously if you bring a pre-prepared
library that's gonna cost less than just
raw DNA and then the data analysis as
well if you're willing to take back raw
DNA that's the cheapest standard data
analysis alignments pretty basic not too
expensive but then if you want something
more that's going to cost you more
another major application is human exome
sequencing and this at a standard is it
100x this one is interesting because
it's it's being used for a variety of
reasons but one of those reasons is that
it's been substantially cheaper than
whole genome sequencing and it's still
true that is cheaper but it's it's not
as the difference in price isn't as
great as it used to be and that's
because the high seek x10 really brought
the prices down but only propulsion
sequencing and not for exome sequencing
so as we see here that the average exome
project price per sample is a couple
hundred bucks less than whole genome
with 1,500 but it's got a huge variation
that the standard deviation is almost
$1000 and and there are some things that
impact that price just like whole genome
the number of samples per project
obviously the more samples you have
cheaper it's going to be for example but
they're much bigger things seems to
actually be the data analysis so with
with whole genome sequencing on the x10
more people seem to be willing to just
get the data back they it's being used
more for just research projects
excellent projects are skewing much more
toward clinical and actual patient
samples and so data analysis becomes
much more important they want that
additional analysis added on the
interpretation of the genome and that's
really going to increase the price quite
a bit so that's why the price difference
between whole genome and exome isn't
quite as high as you might have
otherwise otherwise expecting so the
final kind of major application I want
to talk to you about is RNA seek you
know normalized this to ten million
reads that's kind of on the low end in
terms of what people typically would run
this would give you roughly equivalent
results to a microarray and it's that
it's the lowest price project type that
at least compared to the DNA ones at
little under six hundred dollars per
sample but as you can see that standard
deviation is nearly five hundred so a
huge amount of variation here again kind
of broken record samples for project the
bigger the project you have the cheaper
is going to be for sample but a much
bigger thing that was impacting price in
the project we saw was middling so if
you go with a very simple one by fifty
you know single read 50 base me that's
going to be on the cheaper end if you
want something more involved looking at
splice junctions and things like that
you might win that paired end two
hundred base reads that's going to be a
lot more expensive so that's a huge
factor in determining that the end cost
of these kinds of projects the other
thing that impact of the price pretty
greatly that was a bit of a surprise is
the species so if you're doing something
that's been well studied looking at
human mouse yeast things like that it's
pretty cheap to get analyzed but if
you're doing something that's not so
well studied maybe doesn't have a good
reference genome the price really goes
through the roof and that's probably
because they're essentially you're
asking that provider to run de novo
transcriptome analysis every time so
there's a lot more labor a lot more
work involved in that price really goes
quite high so there's so much variation
here that actually went to show you some
of the data kind of how it spreads out
in histogram you can see over on the
left that the bulk of the projects are
in the two to 300 or $400 range that's
pretty close to probably what people are
paying for a microarray through a core
lab or through a service provider so
that that's it's pretty much parody but
you can see on the right-hand side
things can get very expensive you know
over sixteen seventeen seventeen hundred
dollars per sample and that would be
again for those specialty type of
projects you know maybe a species that
hasn't that even sequence before so it
becomes a true research project okay so
that's kind of what we're seeing today
there's a few things that we would like
to keep an eye on in the future and we
think you might like to do so as well
obviously we expect some improvements
from Illumina so changes to the x10
maybe eventually having being able to
buy just one of those instruments next
one
they actually have already released
something lb x5 so if you don't have the
ten million dollars to buy ten of these
that they will now sell you five of them
for six million dollars so you can save
yourself a bit of money that way
unfortunately they then jack up the
reagent cost when you do that so the
cost for generating whole genome the
exercise system is 1,400 but still it
gives people a way to sort of buy their
way in the other thing that we're
anticipating potentially happening is
getting more applications to open up on
the X 10 they said right now it's only
human whole genome the obvious thing to
do would be to open that for exome
sequencing it turns out there is a hint
that maybe it's actually already been
open that for whole genome bisulfite
sequencing there's one of the service
providers out there tweeted out that
they're doing this offering this little
service and Illumina reach we did it so
they clearly know about it and are happy
with it I don't know any of the details
but it is an interesting clue that at
some point that machine is going to
start opening up to other applications
we're also keeping an eye on those new
platforms you know I already mentioned
that Promethean system
not quite sure when that's going to come
out but if it's able to do all the
things without your mana force as it can
do that's going to be a real
game-changer for people another system
is the complete genomic system from BGI
so complete genomics is a company that
BG I bought a couple years ago and up
until recently it was operated strictly
as a service so you would just send
samples to complete and BGI and they
would process it on their little factory
floor and send you back the data but it
turns out they're actually turning that
into an instrument that they can ship to
people and they have hinted at it in
later this summer they're going to
hopefully tell us more information
basically they've hinted that it's going
to be a lower class system you know
definitely competing to the x10 and
having high quality data so definitely
something to keep an eye on a couple of
the systems that were interested in but
haven't heard too much about is Genesis
and geniu Genesis uses a technology
that's somewhat similar to ion torrent
but they claim through their different
chemistry to be able to get longer reads
and higher-quality reads genie is that
Nana port company had talked about
before they had been releasing updates
to the public letting people know what
was going on since they were purchased
by Roche everything kind of went dark
the good news though is that Roche
appears to be putting money and
resources into that technology so
hopefully they're progressing and
hopefully you know not sure when but at
some point we'll start seeing that
system out in the wild
the last thing really keep an eye on
would be data interpretation standards
not not just the analysis and the
interpretation this is especially
important on the clinical side it's
always a balance of trying to decide
when those standards need to go to be
implemented you know if you bring them
on too early you can actually limit the
advancement but if you wait too long
there especially things like clinical
adoption can really be slowed down
you know physicians who are using this
they don't want to have to guess which
way to align their data which way to do
that snip calling they want some
standards in place that they know they
can rely on they can
what they do today is gonna happen same
tomorrow next week next month next year
so that's something we're looking
forward to as well so that's what I have
for today I appreciate everyone taking
time out
I would also there's some QA that's
going on here so you have any questions
you haven't thought of please put them
in there I would also encourage you to
check out our website follow us on
Twitter and if you have any other
comments or questions that you didn't
think of today please feel free to email
me directly directly thanks a lot
Thank You Sean for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Xuan a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can
my first question is can also sequencing
applications be utilized on the min I am
yeah that's a great that's a great
question can all the applications be
utilized in the min I am I would say not
yet it's it's still in this early access
program so we've seen people do a lot of
interesting things with it
it's obviously being geared more towards
small genomes because the output is
still relatively small you know in the
best cases today people are getting
about a Giga base but a lot of more
typical use might be more like half a
gig or so so it's somewhat limited there
I would say that things like RNA seek
will be a challenge for a little while
until they get the throughput up just
because you tend to need a large number
of reads that said at their London
Calling meeting apparently they talked
about doing RNA sequencing you know they
talked about a number of things real
what's missing so far from that system
is the upfront sample prep and it con
talked about not needing sample prep
they've hinted more than hinted they've
talked about this new instrument whose
name I can't remember they just talked
about it today that's gonna automate
some that sample crap so I think once
that gets out there then we'll start
seeing a lot of other applications
there's no obvious limits to what that
machine should be able to do the only
exception I could think of would maybe
be small RNA it's not that they couldn't
do it but that's probably not going to
be the strength of what that nanopore
system can do which is really good at
looking at long reads obviously that
small reads you not going to get that
advantage
so thanks great question how does one
utilize the early access program the
early access program where the min ion
is what I'm assuming that's relatively
easy you would just apply for it you
know I don't know the details but if you
go to Oxford nanopore s website
they are definitely taking people in for
that and it does not appear to be
particularly exclusive so you know the
more traditional early access program is
really meant to be looking or rather
working with a small number of
researchers who are pretty friendly to
the company is doing it it's highly
controlled that there's a little bit of
that going on but this isn't your
typical early access program there are
there literally hundreds and hundreds of
independent researchers who are doing
this so you know if if you can't have
trouble finding yourself just email me
and I'll help you find the length of
base base just going onto the link
filling out the application deciding how
many you want access to at a time last I
look at this basically it cost you
$1,000 refundable see
her flow cell that you want to work with
at a time looking on five-time that's
$5,000 once you use them I think you
maybe ship these ones back and get a new
one shipped back to you and then just at
that point you're paying shipping costs
so it's not particularly difficult to
get in but you do have to apply next
question regarding cancer targeted gene
sets' what is popular in your view what
are the best options so targeted cancer
gene sets um you know I can't I can't
give you a you know list of specific
genes there are a few solutions out
there basically what people seem to be
focusing on is roughly sets of up to two
to three hundred genes I think that
foundation medicine has roughly 300
genes now and so they're using a
specialized version of targeted
sequencing so one of the issues that you
have with target sequencing is it
doesn't always pull down all the regions
equally well and so what they've done
and probably what some other competitors
have done is they've taken time to kind
of tweet that pulldown process to make
sure that they get uniform coverage that
it's fairly critical in terms of which
ones are best I honestly can't tell you
I can say that they're pretty much all
using the Illumina technology so it's
it's high-quality sequence with some
known limitations but they would sort of
design around those limitations and then
it's maybe not very satisfying but I
guess the only thing I could levy is
it's clearly that foundation medicine is
the leader in that area and you know
they just had a huge influx of cash from
Roche they clearly thought foundation
has something that maybe is a cut above
the rest hopefully that answers your
question
do you think that the next-gen sequence
or producing companies will be willing
to invest in developing sequences with
short leads around one KB for the
projects that only require them instead
of long read for lower prices for will
that portion of the market be forced
into using those next-gen sequencers in
the future not completely sure I
understand the question but I'll answer
it as best I can and then what I would
say is if I don't if I didn't answer
what you're really looking for it just
email me and I'll try to do a better job
in person so what what we're seeing
right now and what's completely
dominating the market just completely
dominating it are the short reads and
that's for a couple reasons the the cost
of those reads on a per base or per
gigabase metric is far and away the low
so the the lowest cost you can get there
with a high cx-10 is about seven dollars
per gigabyte and that that's just so
much lower than all the other all the
other technologies you know haven't
really priced it out exactly but just as
a comparison the PacBio machine which is
producing the longest reads it's able to
generate about a Giga base but the
closer to $500 or $1,000
so it's substantially more expensive per
base to do it that way so because of
that reason short reads are dominating
another reason that short reads are good
is if you can run a lot of them so it's
it's kind of naturally easier to run a
lot of short reads than running a lot of
long reads in general that said if these
other technologies come out and they
continue to improve on generating the
long reads they bring the cost down for
base and if they increase the throughput
so you're getting a lots and lots of
reads they will start to look a lot more
attractive that there generally aren't
any truly inherent advantages to the
short reads it was just
to do so in terms of what the markets
gonna look like it is difficult to say
that my guess in my hope is that we will
see different types of sequencers
serving different types of markets and
the truth is it it's that's true today
it's just that they're mostly coming
from one company so Illumina built the
ICA x10 that's for you know countrywide
sequencing project you want to sequence
everyone in a country or really really
large cohorts and that's the cheapest
per base but then you got on the other
end you get the my seek which is much
more expensive it's it's closer to a
hundred dollars per gig a days but it's
quicker the machines cheaper the output
is smaller so it's really better geared
towards small instruments so I
definitely think you're gonna see
different instruments geared for
different types of applications and you
know Illumina is not the only company to
do that ion torrent is try to do that a
little bit there two machines the PGM
and the proton and Oxford nanopore is
talking about that as well the minion is
going to be that little handheld
portable that can go out in the field
the Promethean is going to be that
bigger instrument not so big so maybe
it'll go in the field as well but that's
going to be more the workhorse if
someone wants to sequence a whole human
genome or several human genomes so yeah
I think you will see lots of different
manifestations of these platforms
serving the different market needs and
again if I didn't answer that exactly
the way you were really looking forward
to please give me an email and I'll try
to do try to give you some more info
great question can you comment on the
cost of RNA seek at 50 M would that be
fifty thousand reads yeah that's 50
million reads and again a good question
the data I showed was actually
normalized at 10 million basically 50
million reads it's obvious it's gonna be
more expensive
it's not gonna be quite five times as
expensive though it's not quite linear
there are some upfront overhead things
sample crap and things like that so you
know I haven't looked at those specific
prices but I'm gonna give a rough
ballpark of getting something closer to
$1,000 roughly roughly in that general
area I will say and it's something that
we actually encourage people to do the
best way to find out what the prices are
is to actually ask the providers
directly and that's why we've built the
sequencing marketplace it's a way for
you to pretty easily get prices from
multiple providers in a really
competitive situation so you can really
get the actual price there but as a
ballpark I'm gonna guess you know maybe
around a thousand dollars do you think
that the cost for WGS will reach the 100
dollar mark or lower in the next five to
ten years that's a really good question
I the answer is that I hope it will it's
a 10 years is really hard even five
years is quite hard in the past prices
have certainly been dropping fast enough
that that would be hit no problem but a
couple of things happened one the more
easy gains that are even made so the
lower you go the harder those gains are
second is that the competition kind of
faded away a little bit and right now
Illumina is a little bit too dominant
they really control prices in this
market so what we need are a couple
things we definitely need to see some
more competition so Oxford nanopore is
certainly saying they're gonna offer
that maybe BGI will come back with their
new genomics and offer competition but
the other thing to realize is that while
the sequencing costs have really come
down a whole lot the sample prep cost
haven't come down so even if you got
sequencing cost down to 100 you still
might be paying 50 or $100 for the
sample prep so in order at some point
if the sequencing comes down far enough
we're really it's gonna put pressure on
other aspects of that whole workflow
upfront sample prep and then also the
downstream data analysis and
interpretation they're going to become
bigger
components to that but certainly based
on the things that we've seen companies
claiming there's no reason to think that
it couldn't hit the hundred dollar mark
as long as the market operates in a
relatively typical fashion being of
competition and that the market space
increases and that's really why all
these sequencing companies they want to
get them the clinical at the clinical
market because that's a much bigger
market than the research market so if
that happens and it happens in a way
that's relatively free market oriented
then that my guess is certainly by 10 a
really hopefully getting down the $100
range and I really hope we do because I
think a lot of really interesting
science and a lot of really interesting
health monitoring is going to start
happening when that sequencing gets that
cheap so yeah great question here we
have time for one last question where do
you see the clinical pharmacogenomics
market in the near term and long term
specifically what about reimbursement
for the testing services that's a really
good question and it's it's a point that
I actually bring up a lot you're gonna
find I was I probably have a very good
answer for you but you did bring up a
really good point people asked you know
what's holding next-gen sequencing back
from the from the clinic you know what
does the technology need to be what does
it need to cost what is the error rate
need to be you know all this kind of
stuff but the truth is the thing that's
really gonna hold it back is that
reimbursement and and the truth is I
just don't know my my guess here and
this is really just my opinion it's not
particularly based on any kind of deep
analysis my guess is that it will be
reimburse
and if it's not reimbursed I think
there'll be such a demand from the end
users or the patients that they'll go
around the normal health system that we
have today so that in at least in the
u.s. I know it's radically different in
other countries here in the US it
matters you know is that procedure
covered by insurance is it reimbursable
and that can be really slow to have
happen and if it's too slow I think that
the patients will demand it and then the
providers will rather respond by having
more rational pricing for people or
actually you know paying their own money
to get it so so it's a little bit tricky
to say I know people are working on this
with a lot of companies who are working
there's new new CPT codes that are out
there that people can start using now to
get next-gen sequencing services
reimbursed but my guess is that the
technology is going to develop so much
faster than the bureaucracy of both the
FDA
and of the health insurance companies
that it might just kind of be taken over
by consumer demand so again really a
great question so I guess that's the
what we had time for I appreciate
everyone attending and I appreciate all
the really wonderful questions you don't
always get good questions you guys did a
wonderful job again I'd encourage you to
check out our website follow us on
Twitter and if I didn't get to your
question or you'd like a little
follow-up please just email me at Shana
I'll see calm again thanks so much for
joining thing today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 14 2015 you'll receive an email
from laggards alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues and may have missed
today's live event see you next time bye